we live in a small solar system in the
suburbs of the Milky Way galaxy
[Music]
eight planets and more than 180 moons
all orbiting the Sun
the town we do whatever the sun wants us
to do
the sun's influence stretches more than
one light year in every direction
defines the boundary of our solar system
some place out there is a place where
the sun's influence ends and the other
stars begin
that's the entrance to Interstellar
space
Interstellar space is the region between
Star systems in our galaxy
until now we've known little about it
for so long we thought of the space and
madars is entirely empty
there's a lot going on out there and
it's the Forefront of astronomy
one of the biggest clues about
Interstellar space came right to our
doorstep
[Music]
October 2017
the pan Stars One telescope spots
something unusual
panstars is an observatory in Hawaii and
it's scanning large sections of the sky
looking for things that change
all of a sudden
in miles an hour
it was a much faster object than what
might be expected for a solar system
object and also its trajectory was such
that it seemed like its orbit was not
bound to the Sun
it was totally unlike any other path any
other trajectory any other orbit in our
solar system
astronomers reached an extraordinary
conclusion
it became very clear that yeah this was
not some solar system object falling
from a long way away this was something
that came from another star and I think
everybody was pretty Amazed by that
foreign
Interstellar visitor on a flyby through
our solar system
it was the very first object that we'd
ever discovered
that had originated outside the solar
system everything else we've seen every
Comet every asteroid originated within
our solar system
a big Mega solid object entering in our
own solar system and that's something
that you know I can only dream of but
had never thought it would actually be a
reality
scientists named the object omuamua
Hawaiian for a messenger from afar
arriving first
[Music]
this theme came from Interstellar space
into our solar system and the main
question is what could it be
the object's shape was mystifying
[Music]
of shaped like a cigar
Ms longer than it is wide
and this is extraordinary there's no
object in our solar system that we've
ever measured that is this elongated
ooh looked so unnatural
it sparked scientists imaginations
one of the things to remember about
scientists is that we're still human
beings we have read science fiction we
have imaginations
I have to admit when I first heard about
it my first thought is that it was Rama
from an Arthur C Clarke Story rendezvous
with Rama this is a very elongated
spaceship that came from another star
it reminded me of some designs we had
for Interstellar spacecrafts that have
to be much longer than their wide in
order to minimize friction with the
interstellar
gas
be an alien Interstellar spacecraft
astronomers including Professor Avi Loeb
took the idea seriously
we decided to follow this object using
the best telescopes in the world and
observe whether there is any radio
transmission from it
astronomers hunted for signs of alien
communication
but after eight hours of listening
across multiple frequencies
nothing
sadly no emissions were detected it's
almost certainly a natural object I
would bet all of my money on that I was
disappointed I would have been much more
excited if we have found evidence for an
alien civilization
thank you
no little green man this time
amuamua is a natural object
but what exactly is it
at first observers thought it might be a
comet
something that's mostly ice with a
little bit of rock those are the sorts
of bodies that exist really far out from
the Star and are the easiest things to
eject
but a comet passing this close to the
Sun would warm up
turning the ice into a gas forming a
vapor trail
[Music]
on a muamua astronomers saw no sign of
this happening
there was no fuzziness around it that
you would expect from a comet as the ice
was turned into a gas
it was really mysterious and so
everybody who was observing it thought
it was an asteroid
as teams tracked the muamua across the
sky
there was an unexpected twist
as omuamua passed through our solar
system it basically was falling in
toward the sun speeding up immensely as
it passed the sun before exiting the
solar system in almost the opposite
direction
but then something weird happened as it
was moving away from the Sun it was
slowing down as you'd expect but it
wasn't slowing down fast enough
gets a boost through our solar system
but how
so we think the reason is that it's
outgassing
in other words it was emitting a little
bit of gas and that was acting as a
little bit of a rocket motor push on it
it's kind of like a little jet engine on
the surface it just gives it a little
thrust over time
this tiny nudge reveals amuamua's true
identity
so in that case it is looking more like
a comet it's just that that emission
wasn't enough to see
powered by outgassing this Interstellar
Nomad might travel from star to star but
figuring out where in the Galaxy it came
from just got more difficult
now that we know that omuamua has
outgassed which changes its velocity and
changes its trajectory it makes it much
harder to do that
[Music]
may now be safely racing away but the
solar system faces bombardment from
another Interstellar Source
firing at Earth at close to the speed of
light
cosmic rays are the bullets of the
universe and they are flooding
Interstellar space